hey yes what's up this is andrew for
chances.com so in this video i would
like
with you to have a look at some stocks
that have for me a nice setup so either
we have a breakout or we are almost
having a breakout
so those stocks that i'm monitoring guys
and i'm trying to share information
whenever i see it
with you in my discord very soon i'm
gonna have a screener a powerful
tool you know that just gives me all the
signals so i'm gonna share it with you
of course guys
so let's see what we're having for today
let's get into it
[Music]
all right so i'm going to start with a
snap guys so this is a very
nice setup so basically the eliot wave
counting is pretty clean
since 2019 one two three four five moves
up go higher
in five waves corrective moves are done
in three waves
here moves down and then here we're
having one two three
four with the triangle so triangle
almost always
occur in the false waves so whenever you
see a triangle be careful guys
the difference between a triangle and a
wedge all right a wedge is like this
so this is bearish when you have those
two
going higher if you have a pattern like
this with here making higher highs
this is bearish right but when it's
making lower highs
then it's a triangle and then it's
bullish so this is a bullish pattern
with the breakouts so i'm sorry i'm
giving you this trade only here guys
but it's still a very nice setup so the
best would have been to buy the breakout
retest as
i like to do around 60 but i did i
didn't see it at that time
once again i will very soon see all
these things and give it to you guys on
my discord so go there
it's still for free i'm gonna announce
next week the different membership
chairs
i'm gonna try to give you as much value
as possible in the evening the lower
tiers memberships but definitely where
i'm gonna bring the more value
is gonna be in the highest ones where
i'm gonna manage different portfolio
with a clean track record but i'm gonna
give you all the information about the
trades before i do them
i'm gonna risk manage it just like i was
doing at work so it's gonna be very
professional
uh some super excited guys about that
project i'm hiring
some traders right now guys they are
very good very it's very promising
but whatever so here we're gonna have
everything that we need
to see those uh earlier now what can you
do here guys we're having
a nice triangle breakout with that very
strong move that happened on friday
with a weekly close at you know gap up
which we closed
just above the all-time high very nice
setup
so some of the traders in the team there
are momentum trailers so they would buy
right now i'm not like that so they
would buy right now so
that's why it's going to be so
interesting as we're going to see the
different techniques used by
the different traders you know i
wouldn't buy here but you know
some traders they like to follow those
hard
those sharp gap apps and those with
associated with strong volume and they
just buy
and whenever the price is going down
they sell all right but you need to
monitor it's a day trading
technique here what i would do guys if
you're not
in this trade yet as usual guys and this
is working i'm telling you it's working
you wait for the retest and bam you
enter so we might go very high we might
go to 90
hundred so you're gonna feel like oh
you're gonna feel for more
like you want to formal but ultimately
we're gonna have this retest
it might take one week it might take one
month it might take three months we're
gonna have it
and then we're gonna go higher so this
is what usually happens
so this is a very nice setup next one
and i oh
so this one same thing i talked a lot
about this one on my discord i mean a
lot
i did like two analysis on it i'm not
bullish yet guys but let's uh monitor
what is happening here if we have a
breakout above 50 it looks good
this force wave might be complete all
right it's possible we are like that
it's possible all right it's not my
preferred scenario but we might be like
this
abc in this case we would break so if we
break
51 once again i'm gonna tell you guys if
i see it
and then here nice level to buy the
breakout retest
my preferred scenario guys is we go
lower and so here the nice level to buy
would be 21. so if we move lower here
so it's a very big drop guys so i'm not
sure this would happen you know it's
like a 50
drop but uh don't be that surprised if
it happens don't be that surprised all
right we're gonna have for me here some
rejection
we have some supports before
okay 31 is definitely a support all the
30 area
is going to be supporting the price as
well so a trade idea would be to buy the
30 by the 20
or wait for the breakout and buy the
retest but this is going higher guys
this is looking good
uh tesla tesla very interesting guys i'm
posting about tesla almost every day
same thing guys elliott wave is fitting
very well sorry for this
you know very messy counting but it's
actually very detailed
now it's better okay and here we're
waiting so one two three four we're
waiting for the fifth wave
and we are waiting for the breakout guys
we're not we're not having it i'm
posting on it since like three weeks
we are just grinding lower following
this downward sloping trend line
and here we are supported we have some
build up all right
it's pretty obvious here that some
buyers
are buying here on the moving averages
you have this long build up position
this long position build up that is
happening here
and once again we are very close to
breakout guys
we have this consolidation here okay so
i think this counting is like this right
now
this is a fourth and we're waiting for a
fifth so whenever we break out
above 660 something like this
it looks very good here guys there might
be no retest not right now
why because we are consolidating low
for already some time so the market has
energy so it can
it can do like this it can definitely go
much higher here
before correcting so of course you're
gonna have one more opportunity here
but maybe we're not gonna have the
retest here all right
i don't see something like this in this
case we will go higher because we are
stuck here for a long time and there is
a long position build up that is pretty
obvious here
so whatever it's going to break out it's
going to be strong and
with very shallow pullbacks so watch out
what is happening here once again i'm
going to let you know whenever i see
something
last but not least football tv
same situation guys nice elliott wave
counting i'm not gonna
go through this here with you i'm just
gonna give you the important information
is that we are moving higher since we
had this huge correction breakout at
18 that i gave you as well on my channel
guys
then one two three four five we move
higher now we are correcting so let me
go on the hourly time frame
and see if the breakout here so i'm
posting regularly about this on my
discord as well
here okay let's make it perfect yes
we're breaking out
we are breaking out the breakout is
confirmed on the hourly
if monday we open higher okay it's not
confirmed on the four hours i have only
one candle but it's it's looking nice we
have here
a fake out clearly you see on the
flowers i need to move a bit the trend
line okay
here we have a fake out it's not a fake
out because it's not a breakout actually
we didn't close above this level so it's
not a breakout
and here we are okay we're struggling
guys but definitely
fugu opens higher at the open it's a
very
nice setup to go along everything
between
27 and 28 is good to buy for me
it's good to buy for me i think we're
going to go higher and it can be
strong as well because we are
consolidating here for a while
as you can see guys it's totally
different than for example when we were
here
you can see here we arrived here
suddenly with a lot of strength
but no correction no consolidation so of
course the market cannot hold
here is completely different we are
hovering around this level for some time
we are of course having the bullish
divergences
here uh that is suggesting that so
that's gonna
act you know this whole time so here
it's gonna help us a bit
it's suggesting we're gonna have a
breakout and we're gonna move lower my
targets
are much higher guys all right i have a
target around 60
for the third wave so let's find out
what is happening guys i think that all
the stocks are very interesting to
follow i'm gonna keep following those
i'm gonna keep posting guys daily
updates
on my discord about that so i hope you
enjoyed this video i hope i managed to
explain once again how i use my tools
and how i
get my signals using them so if you
enjoyed this video please don't forget
to click on the sub
like and bell button so i'm gonna be the
first to know when i upload anything
new and stay close to shore see you guys